perché è una torta di mele
perché oggi sono qui per parlarvi di
cibo ma troppo spesso il cibo viene
confuso con la chimica se chiedete una
persona cosa mangia nella maggior parte
dei casi di risponderà proteine
carboidrati grassi vitamine
i più informati si spingeranno oltre
inizieranno a parlarvi di omega 3 e
omega 6 licopeni e tantissime sostanze
dal nome impronunciabile
morale non avete la più pallida idea di
cosa mangi quella persona
vedete il paradosso del giorno d'oggi si
parla di cibo senza parlare di cibo io
stessa sostengo l'importanza della
chimica consiglio alle persone di
assumere tutti i nutrienti necessari
ma se ci limitiamo alla chimica perdiamo
di vista tutto il resto e vi assicuro
che è davvero tanto
ecco perché ho deciso di partire dalla
torta di mele la torta di mele è un cibo
concreto appartiene a tutte le famiglie
fa parte della nostra esperienza
e sì perché il cibo è innanzitutto un
esperienza prima di assaggiare un piatto
iniziamo a gustarlo con la vista con
l'olfatto con il tatto se scrocchia
anche con l'udito e solo alla fine lo
assaporiamo con il gusto
ma il cibo e anche emozioni suggestioni
ricordi la torta di mele che ci
preparava la nonna la domenica per
festeggiare il cibo è anche condivisione
e convivialità
il cibo è l'effetto che ha sul nostro
corpo e il cibo e anche l'ambiente il
seme che viene piantato nella terra
l'acqua che lo bar il sole che lo scalda
il vento che lo accarezza e quella forza
profonda che lo fa germogliare e lo
trasforma nel nostro cibo
ecco perché sono proprio convinta che
consumare cibo biologico
stagionale e possibilmente locale sia
davvero importante non solo per la
salute del nostro pianeta ma anche per
noi stessi per creare equilibrio tra noi
e l'ambiente nel quale viviamo
provate a farci caso
siamo quasi in inverno e la natura per
noi che viviamo in lombardia nella
pianura padana
inizia a offrirci tutta la frutta e la
verdura che più vengono cotti e più
diventano buoni più diventano dolci e ci
permettono così di preparare dei piatti
riscaldanti per compensare il freddo e
l'umido che ci sono fuori
allo stesso modo
l'estate è la stagione della frutta e
della verdura più fresca più succosa per
creare umidità nel nostro corpo e
aiutarci a su a sopportare il fresco il
caldo scusate il secco che ci sono fuori
d'altronde non dobbiamo inventarci nulla
basterebbe guardare la natura cosa fanno
le piante in autunno
iniziano a perdere le foglie e spingono
la linfa sottoterra in profondità per
superare i rigori dell'inverno per poi
riesplodere in primavera in un tripudio
di fiori e di colori vedete non dobbiamo
davvero inventare niente
ma torniamo al tema della nostra
giornata il titolo di questa giornata è
ricetta futuro ma se vogliamo parlare di
cibo e di futuro dobbiamo per forza
rivolgere uno sguardo al passato il cibo
deve tornare ad essere una scelta noi
oggi viviamo in un mondo saturo di
informazioni tutti hanno il prodotto
magico per risolvere tutti i nostri
problemi e te spesso tendiamo a da
accettare questi suggerimenti in modo
passivo ma il cibo invece deve tornare
ad essere una scelta di salute e
benessere
oltre che di piacere
d'altronde mangiare è una cosa che
facciamo tutti per tutta la vita uomini
e donne anziani e bambini e quindi può
diventare davvero uno strumento per il
cambiamento
avete mai sentito la storia della rana
bollita è la storia di una povera rana
che viene messa in una pentola piena
d'acqua e quest'acqua viene riscaldata
molto lentamente e quindi povera lei si
abitua gradualmente alla temperatura
sempre più calda dell'acqua
finché alla fine muore bollita
purtroppo questa è una situazione che
vedo molto spesso nella nostra società
c'è un senso di rassegnazione diffusa
abbiamo imparato a convivere
quotidianamente con dolori disturbi
fastidi e pensiamo che questa sia la
normalità ma soprattutto la cosa più
grave è che pensiamo che questo non
possa cambiare ma in realtà non è così
il mio invito è di trovare la forza di
saltare fuori da questa pentola di
prendere in mano la nostra vita e la
nostra salute perché ricordate che la
salute non è solo assenza di malattia
la salute è uno stato di benessere
fisico ma anche psichico emotivo siri
spirituale e sociale
noi siamo quello che mangiamo
vi siete mai interrogati sul profondo
significato di questa frase che ormai è
diventata un po uno slogan e quasi sulla
bocca di tutti
significa che noi possiamo giorno dopo
giorno vasto dopo pasto scegliere
consapevolmente di costruire il nostro
benessere
ma per fare questo è necessaria un'altra
cosa dobbiamo tornare in cucina dobbiamo
ricominciare
scenari
avete mai notato come è cambiata nel
corso della storia
il ruolo della cucina nelle nostre case
un tempo la cucina era la stanza
principale della casa
la più grande è riscaldata sempre
animata e magari con una pentola di
zuppa sempre pronta sul fuoco
oggi come sono le nostre cucine sono
piccole magari bellissime con gli
elettrodomestici di ultima generazione
ma morte asettiche ci passiamo
pochissimo tempo tante volte
giusto il tempo necessario per scaldare
del cibo già pronto e consumarlo
velocemente da soli in piedi o
appoggiati un bancone quindi veramente
torniamo in cucina e riscopriamo la
gioia di cucinare
a questo proposito vi voglio lasciare
due indicazioni che mi hanno aiutato in
questi anni a non perdere la rotta il
primo principio dice la teoria senza
pratica è inutile la pratica senza
teoria e pericolosa quindi continuate
pure a informarvi siamo fortunati ad
accedere a tutte le informazioni che
abbiamo a disposizione
ma non dimenticate di metterli in
pratica
sperimentate su noi stessi ascoltate i
segnali che il vostro corpo vi manda
e solo dopo decidete se quella cosa va
bene o meno per voi un altro principio
importante è che la quantità modifica la
qualità quindi non è detto che se una
cosa fa bene presa dieci volte faccia
dieci volte bene anzi potrebbe anche
avere delle controindicazioni
quindi diffidate delle soluzioni
miracolose che con una singola cosa vi
risolvono i problemi della vita
la varietà è una scelta vincente
questi due principi vi consiglio di
iscrivervi su un foglietto e di attaccar
veli in casa in un luogo dove passate
spesso che sia lo specchio del bagno la
porta del frigorifero poco importa ma
leggeteli ogni tanto e vedrete che vi
aiuteranno a
questo punto mi direte bene e allora che
cosa dobbiamo mangiare anche qui se
vogliamo parlare di cibo e futuro
dobbiamo guardare un pochino indietro
quello che vi propongo oggi non ha
niente di rivoluzionario
vi propongo semplicemente di recuperare
ciò che tutte le grandi civiltà hanno
mangiato e consumato per millenni tra
parentesi siccome sono una sostenitrice
della sperimentazione
queste scelte sono state anche quelle
che mi hanno permesso di conquistare
benessere vitalità lucidità chiarezza
mentale ma che soprattutto mi hanno
aiutato a superare una prova importante
come possono essere due tumori
[Applauso]
grazie
alla base della nostra piramide abbiam i
cereali dove per cereali non intendo i
con flex della colazione intendo il
cereale nella forma più integra e
primitiva i cereali in chicco che ha la
forza di germogliare e che ci porta
questa forza nel corpo poi non vuol dire
non mangiare più la pasta la polenta o i
cereali della colazione ma impariamo ad
usare di nuovo il chicco
abbiamo poi legumi di nuovo dei semi vi
ricordate a scuola quando ce li facevano
mettere nel cotone poi li annaffiava moe
germogliavano ecco di nuovo una fonte di
energia vera per il nostro corpo e poi
abbiamo le verdure le verdure vanno
d'accordo con la parola varietà
usate varietà nella scelta delle forme
dei colori del modo in cui le tagliate
degli stili di cottura
vedrete che le verdure vi offrono
veramente un panorama infinito di gusti
e di consistenze le verdure ciò che sono
ciò che crea elasticità nel nostro corpo
così come i semi i cereali e legumi
creano invece forza profonda e poi
abbiamo tanti altri elementi abbiamo dei
condimenti di buona qualità come può
essere il nostro olio extravergine di
oliva o del sale marino integrale
abbiamo semi oleosi e frutta secca dei
dolci di buona qualità un po di frutta e
poi un pochino di cibi fermentati i
famosi probiotici quelli che fanno così
bene al nostro intestino e che ci
permettono di rafforzare il nostro
sistema immunitario e visti i tempi che
corrono
direi che ne può valere la pena
ma il consiglio più grande che voglio
darvi ed a portare a casa oggi è di non
accettare passivamente quello che vi sto
raccontando
andate a casa e provate a sperimentare
vedete se veramente di porta dei
benefici
certo
cambiare alimentazione una scelta che
comporta impegno dedizione e anche un po
di conoscenze ma c'è il vantaggio che se
non dovete fare tutto velocemente perché
avete magari un problema di salute da
risolvere potete andare per gradi potete
procedere per addizione e non per
sottrazione
dedicate le vostre energia qualche nuova
cosa che volete introdurre nella vostra
vita e per forza d'inerzia ciò che non è
più in armonia tenderà ad andarsene
avete mai letto questa parola da qualche
parte per i tempi è una parola latina e
quando la scoperta me ne sono subito
innamorata è una parola che significa
passo passo ma purtroppo in italiano non
esiste una singola parola equivalente
noi oggi viviamo nella società del tutto
e subito una società veloce che non ha
pazienza che non ci permette di
prenderci il tempo necessario
ecco il mio consiglio è di prendervi
tutto il tempo necessario
potete iniziare aggiungendo una prima
nuova abitudine una prima nuova azione
che in soli dieci giorni può diventare
un'abitudine
dieci giorni è un termine molto
importante è il tempo che serve al
nostro plasma per rigenerarsi cosa
c'entra il plasma questo punto mi
chiederete voi il plasma e la parte più
liquida del nostro sangue e quella che
raccoglie le sostanze nutritive
assimilate dall'intestino e le porte in
giro per il corpo e le fa diventare i
nostri tessuti i nostri organi ma anche
le nostre emozioni e i nostri sentimenti
quindi vedete come cambiare la qualità
del nostro plasma può innescare
veramente una rivoluzione silenziosa
un consiglio da dove partire vi
consiglio di partire da qui
questo condimento si chiama gomasio è un
condimento salato a base appunto di sale
tostato e semi di sesamo tostati e poi
il tutto viene macinato in un mortaio
che si chiama su ribassi con un pestello
che si chiama surico oggi è un
condimento anche un po poetico perché
rappresenta l'unione del sale che è la
parte più young il maschile con l'olio
di sesamo che la parte più in il
femminile formando un condimento nuovo
ed estremamente
equilibrato andrebbe tenuto in tavola è
aggiunto ai piatti una volta terminata
la cottura per insaporirli perché il
sale andrebbe usato solo in cottura il
vantaggio è che lo trovate già pronto
nei negozi biologici quindi basta a
comprarlo tenerlo in tavola e ricordarsi
di aggiungerlo ai vostri piatti
certo non è introducendo un gomasio che
vi cambierà la vita per questo avrei
altri consigli da darvi ma si tratta pur
sempre di un primo piccolo passo
significativo
e come diceva il famoso scrittore e
filosofo cinese lao tzu anche un viaggio
di mille miglia
inizia con un piccolo passo buoni
piccoli passi a tutti
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]